[Music]
welcome back to science clique today
supersymmetry
what is asymmetry
a symmetry is a transformation that does
not affect an object
a sphere is symmetric under rotations
a butterfly under reflections
a grid under translations
identifying the symmetries of an object
helps understand its geometric structure
our universe has symmetries too
the laws of nature do not change after
certain transformations
for instance
physics does not change from one point
to another the universe is symmetric
under translations
another example if we carry out an
experiment in one direction the result
is the same as in another direction
the universe is symmetric under
rotations
by identifying more and more complex
symmetries physicists have refined our
understanding of the world
[Music]
but have we identified every symmetry of
the universe are there any new ones to
discover
perhaps
supersymmetry is precisely a new kind of
symmetry which we have never observed so
far
[Music]
let's quickly review our current models
nowadays the universe is described as a
block space-time in which particles
evolve
there are two families of particles
which we classify in the standard model
fermions which constitute
matter and bosons which mediate
interactions
supersymmetry postulates that the
standard model is incomplete there are
other particles we've never seen before
each standard particle would have a
super partner in the other category
such that there would be a new boson for
each fermion and a new fermion for each
boson
the fermions electron quarks neutrinos
would each have a boson partner
selectron squawks neutrinos
while bosons photon gluon zw higgs
would each have a fermion partner
photino gluino xeno hexino
supersymmetry is the hypothetical
symmetry between particles of matter and
interaction
researchers are interested in this
hypothesis because it could solve many
mysteries
by adding new particles supersymmetry
offers promising candidates to explain
the nature of dark matter
this invisible mass whose composition
remains a puzzle
another example it is believed that at
the big bang 13 billion years ago
electromagnetism
the strong and the weak interactions
three fundamental interactions of the
universe were merged together
nowadays these interactions have
different intensities but winding back
the clock to the big bang the three
forces should converge
this is grand unification an idea that
could lead to a theory of everything
unfortunately the standard model
calculations seem to indicate that the
curves miss each other
by adding supersymmetry the calculations
now predict that the curves meet in
accordance with ground unification
[Music]
but why do physicists focus mainly on
supersymmetry
one might think that other symmetries
are just as interesting to study
in reality
only supersymmetry seems to be a
reasonable hypothesis
to understand we will have to go back to
our current models
on the one hand the fabric of the
universe is described as an immense grid
space-time
space-time has symmetries
its laws are invariant
from point to point
orientation to orientation
moment to moment
and from an inertial frame to another
space-time obeys these four symmetries
which are called poincare symmetries
they are the symmetries of special
relativity
on the other hand the universe is filled
with particles described as disturbances
within quantum fields
there is one quantum field for each type
of particle a field for electrons a
field for photons and so on
these quantum fields are mathematical
fluids that fill all space
the higgs field is made up of numbers
the fields of the other bosons are made
up of vectors
and the fields of fermions are made up
of spinners
weird mathematical objects which
describe this type of particle very well
these three types of fields are
distinguished by a property called spin
spin 0 and 1 for bosons and a half for
fermions
spin is directly related to which
mathematical objects make up these
quantum fields
to understand the core of supersymmetry
we first need a technical aside
the quantum fields of bosons are
described by numbers
or vectors of numbers
[Music]
in the world of numbers multiplication
is commutative
if we take two numbers like 3 and five
three times five equals fifteen and so
does five times three
more generally x times y equals y times
x
however spinners which describe fermions
are not made up of ordinary numbers but
of weirder objects called grassmann
numbers
despite their name these grassman
numbers are not really numbers they are
abstract mathematical tools
in the world of grasman numbers a times
b is equal to minus b times a
grassman numbers are anti-commutative
in consequence the square of a grassman
number is always zero
this is a very strange property which
obviously does not hold with ordinary
numbers
but we can construct such abstract
objects within the world of mathematics
and they turn out to be very useful to
describe particles of matter
this difference between ordinary numbers
and grassman numbers fundamentally
distinguishes fermions from bosons
we can multiply an ordinary number by
itself which implies that two identical
bosons can be put in the same place at
the same time
but we can't do the same thing with two
fermions
because it's impossible to multiply a
grassman number by itself this always
gives zero
this is the pauli exclusion principle
two fermions cannot be simultaneously in
the same state
this explains why we do not fall through
our chairs
electrons cannot pass through each other
[Music]
let's close the parenthesis and come
back to symmetries
we have seen that space-time obeys four
symmetries the poincare symmetries
however some quantum fields also have
symmetries
quarks for instance come in three
versions red green and blue which are
interchangeable
this is an internal symmetry within the
quark fields
another example the fields of charged
particles such as electrons are
invariant when we alter the phase of
complex numbers
[Music]
this is another example of asymmetry
internal to these quantum fields
in
1967 the physicist coleman and mandula
proved mathematically that the universe
cannot obey any other type of symmetry
the only types of symmetries allowed are
those of poincare from space-time
and the internal symmetries specific to
each quantum field
the theorem forbids any other type of
symmetry
however in 1971 golfing and lichtman
discovered a loophole
the coleman mandula theorem is based on
an assumption it assumes that all
symmetries are quantified by numbers
to bypass this assumption
golfan and lichtman imagined a new kind
of symmetry which would be described not
by numbers but by grassmann numbers
in this case the coleman mandula theorem
does not apply it does not forbid such
asymmetry
this is supersymmetry
in our current models it is thought to
be the only possible extension to the
types of symmetries we already know
an intuitive way to visualize
supersymmetry is to imagine that
space-time is split into two copies
one made of numbers
the other made of grassman numbers
one is the world of bosons
the other are fermions
supersymmetry is the idea of a
translational symmetry from one
space-time to the other a translation
which interchanges numbers and grassman
numbers
bosons and fermions
this is not just a pretty picture we
call this super space we can describe
the universe as two complementary spaces
one for numbers the other for grassman
numbers
and each quantum field would fill up
this whole superspace
such that each particle has a partner in
the other category
it is an abstract construction but a
powerful tool to describe supersymmetry
when it was theorized it was hoped that
supersymmetry could solve a crucial
problem the mass of the higgs boson
the higgs boson interacts with virtual
particles of the quantum vacuum and
according to calculations all these
interactions should make it very heavy
however in reality it seems much lighter
supersymmetry was supposed to provide a
solution to this problem by adding super
particles the quantum vacuum would be
filled with as many fermions as bosons
and their contributions being opposite
they would cancel each other out
unfortunately for this explanation to
work partner particles must have a
similar mass as their contributions
should balance out
but at the moment no super partner has
yet been detected
which indicates that if they do exist
the super partners are necessarily more
massive than we thought otherwise we
would have detected them
in other words our universe does not
seem to obey supersymmetry at least not
in its most exact form supersymmetric
particles might exist but they would
necessarily have a higher mass than
their partners
researchers wonder whether the universe
obeyed supersymmetry in its first
moments just after the big bang
and then broke it as it cooled down
to sum up after decades of research
supersymmetry remains a hypothesis of
which we know that it is not valid in
its most ideal form
but it's still a crucial research topic
as it is probably the only new symmetry
that our current models do not forbid
supersymmetry introduces a duality
between bosons and fermions which could
solve many mysteries and whose
mathematical formalism has helped
several other fields along
supersymmetry is not a theory it is just
a kind of symmetry that the universe may
or may not have
several models use supersymmetry
and by putting it to the test
experimentally we can restrict these
models and refine our research
it is notably used in superstring theory
one of the most promising approaches to
unifying general relativity and quantum
physics
particles are described as tiny
vibrating strings which would have a
super symmetry along their surface
it is also the basis for super gravity a
model that combines supersymmetry and
general relativity
and predicts a super partner for the
graviton the particle of gravity the
gravitino
finally we can build models of universes
with multiple supersymmetries
but there is a limit to the number of
symmetries we can add
we talk of maximal supergravity
in such a model if space-time had 11
dimensions all constants of the universe
turn out to be determined solely by its
symmetries
[Music]
this is a model that was discovered in
france during the 1970s
the quantum version of this model
proposed by witten in 1995
could unify all versions of string
theory
this
is m theory
[Music]
[Music]
you